Let's get some more practice working with data frames. You downloaded
an R script earlier and saw how we can save our
work and run an R code from it. For your next
task, you're going to download an RMD file and run code in
it. You can download the RMD file from the link in
the instructor notes. The file will look something like this. Notice
how this file is slightly different from the file that you
saw before. An R script can only have R code and comments.
This file, however, the RMD file, allows us to do
so much more. It's an R Markdown document, or RMD.
Now, you might be wondering what R Markdown is. And
basically, it's a simple formatting language that let's us author web
pages. If you want to know all you can do with
Markdown then go to Help and then go to Markdown Quick
Reference. This would bring up the documentation for Markdown, and
you can scroll through some of the examples in the formatting.
We've also included a video in the instructor notes that will
go through Markdown. So far this file only contains text that
will be formatted using Markdown. Let's add some R code to
this. We can do this by clicking on Chunks and then
going to Insert Chunk. Now if you're friendly with the keyboard,
you can use the shortcut Cmd+Option+I. There's many other shortcuts in
here and you can see them here in this menu. Here
I've added some code to see what this data set is.
This is the cars data set that also comes with R,
and it contains 50 observations of speeding and stopping distances for
cars in the 1920s. I'm going to add this text as the
title to this document, so that way it's more descriptive of my
file. I'll also run the Str command on this data frame,
so that way I can see what's inside of it. It looks
like I have two variables, speed and distance, which are measured
in miles per hour and feet. Not only can we run R
code and get the output from these files, we can
also embed images. This plot function comes with a base
graphics package in R. But don't worry learning more about
it. We'll be using the ggplot2 package which is
a powerful graphics language in the coming lessons. When I
run this code I get a simple plot of speed
versus distance. Now, what's really amazing about this document is
that we can click the Knit HTML button. This will generate
a web page that includes both content, as well as the output
of any embedded R code. This simple button allows us to easily
share and publish our work. That's enough about RMD files. Let's have
you work in one now. Download the RMD file if you haven't already,
and run and write code when you're prompted to do so. At
the end of the file, you'll come across a question. I want you
to answer that question for this next quiz. And then you can
continue on with the rest of the lesson. Good luck and have fun.